it's been two weeks since we last
visited the service dogs in training of
doggie do-good which means it's been two
weeks since I've seen kya which means
we're going to look at her for a second
and she's the best but today's not
kaya's big day
it's Damien's today is his final exam if
he passes Damien will go to his forever
family tomorrow if he flunks the test
however it could mean months before
Damien is ready or the family may need
to find a different service dog good
luck buddy this is what you puppy
prepped for me
[Music]
for Damien's final exam the trainer's at
doggy do-good have chosen a local mall
with slick floors steep stairs and
distractions of Plenty only the truly
ready pups can get through all of their
drills without issue before going inside
it's time for some warm-up drills by the
parking garage places you and I wouldn't
think twice about are sometimes perfect
places to test the pups for instance
this great unfamiliar surfaces like
these can distract a dog seemingly
without explanation greats can also be
the source of confusing smells and
sounds further throwing a dog off its
game first up Luke the eight month old
golden has been a model student so far a
simple steel grate won't bother Oh
[Music]
how about that his tail wags but Luke
can't wait to get off the metal you can
see his hesitation as he continues to
cross the sound and moving surface
confuses him we may think it's a silly
fear but it's a good reminder that Luke
is still a puppy Karen makes the golden
paws on the grape and feeds him treats
hopefully this will get him to fear the
great a little less after a few more
back-and-forth Luke gets more
comfortable this is good at this stage
Luke just needs to show progress towards
overcoming his fears even for something
as small as a great with Luke scared of
the great
it could mean his sister kaya inherited
a similar fear now the eight month old
crosses the medal with grace and poise
well done kaya way to show your brother
what's what next it's time for Luke and
kaya's half-sister remi to cross the
great the trainers are curious to see if
she'll be brave like her sister or
scared like her brother with that
stutter step it looks like remi is the
exact average of her siblings not as
frightened as luke but definitely more
cautious than kaya still she's more
curious than scared a good sign for the
eight month old with the goldens done
its Bonelli's turn only two weeks ago
the six month old completely shut down
at the bus station if she has a similar
reaction to the great it could spell
disaster for the lavs chances of staying
in school
but Benelli handles the great like a
champion she stands still and even keeps
her tail wagging when Paul tries to
distract her the puppy's made huge
strides in her courage the last two
weeks exactly what the trainers needed
from her the other puppy with bravery
issues is our man about town mr. pip
though he hesitates the Yorkshire
Terrier has little say in the matter
when a trainer can pick you up and move
you wherever she sees fit you're gonna
have to face your demons mr. pip is
presented with a dilemma satisfy his
unshakable craving for treats or flee
like a coward again Karin makes his
decision for him good enough mr. pip
your strengths lie elsewhere and that's
just fine
[Music]
finally it's Damien's turn even with a
pack in his mouth this is more of a
formality than a real test like a senior
taking an introductory class that he
forgot he needed the yellow lab doesn't
disappoint
Damien knows he has to deliver and he
does just that his real test awaits him
inside the mall
[Music]
noises people food deals deals deals the
dogs need to overcome all these
distractions and more inside the mall
the pups go into down-stay of the food
court and while Luke naps Benelli begins
the mall obstacle course the first
challenge the stairs this mall has very
slippery very steep stairs already the
floppy is puppy Benelli immediately has
issues but with her tail wagging she's a
good sport
Benelli has to resist her natural urge
to sprint up the stairs a heel is a heel
even with uneven slippery footing
that's it Benelli almost there okay okay
good good good girl
she's just so floppy
now upstairs Benelli practices hurt get
it commander
[Music]
even with the lights and sounds of the
arcade Benelli keeps checking in with
her trainer this shows great progress in
Bonelli's focus as Benelli returns to
the food court its kaya's turn around
the mall I challenge you to find me a
more perfect dog anywhere it simply
can't be done even amongst the charms of
the arcade our girl can't be phased kaya
is even comfortable lying down inside a
video game on our way back downstairs
kaya is patient and attentive exactly
what her trainers are looking for as
luke drifts in and out of sleep he
wonders if it's his turn nope mr. pips
up back to sleep
the stairs that Benelli struggled with
are a piece of cake for the undeniable
mr. pip he scales them like a mountain
climber summits a peak in the arcade mr.
Pitts practices his comfort belt he'll
be going to a family with children and
if they call upon him amongst the lights
and sounds of an amusement hall he'll
have to perform before leaving the
arcade mr. pip obliges a quick photo
request in the comforts of the
motorcoach ride like any brave
Mountaineer who conquers a pinnacle what
goes pup must come down
imagine if stairs were as big as you are
our brave mr. pip doesn't have to he's
step sized and he handles the challenge
with aplomb in the arcade Luke works on
some drills but it appears some of the
distractions might be a bit too much for
the eight month old golden when trainer
Karen puts the pup in a down state to
familiarize him with the stimuli Luke
rebels Luke's future owners need him to
be alright in a down state anywhere so
if he can't become comfortable in this
arcade it could mean a big problem for
his training progress
Lieut breaks another down-stay
[Music]
eventually with Karen and constant eye
sight Luke is all right after the
confinement of the downs day the golden
retriever is more than happy to practice
his pressure therapy Luke returns to the
food court it's been an
uncharacteristically shaky day for the
golden like people service dogs have
good days and bad at the end of their
training the hope will be to have as few
days like this as possible
[Music]
one dog who's had some bad days lately
is Remy it appears however she's made
great improvement the last few weeks
she's checking in with trainer Paul and
doing well in her heal even in the
arcade the eight month old is attentive
and focused
not at all like she was at the beach a
few weeks ago and like her half-sister
Kaia Remy is prepared to work inside of
the video game console giving Paul hugs
amongst the frightening zombies on the
stairs
Remy shows patience that was totally
absent a week ago she's maturing a
wonderful sign for her schooling
Damien's been training years for this if
he passes tomorrow morning
he and trainer Paul will set off to his
forever family if he fails it doesn't
look good for Damian's continued
enrollment Damian's classmates wish him
luck as he sets off first challenge the
stairs while the younger puppies could
slip around Damian's future owners will
depend on him being steady whenever
called upon tolerance for sliding is
almost nil making it even more difficult
Paul applies periodic pressure to
Damian's harness ensuring the lab is
ready to accept his owners wait still
Damien is able to match Paul's pace
perfectly even when it gets awkward for
the pups footing step by step Damian
proves his patience and dependability on
the stairs the first part of his test is
over and so far so good what's this a
pop quiz in the middle of an exam
Paul's dropped his wallet but Damien
retrieves it with no problem now Damien
will have to carry the trainer's pack
though we did well with this earlier in
the day consistency is the key to
graduation and our guy is steady back it
down stay the puppy's weight nervously
rooting for their friends success it's
all right mr. pip so far Damien's doing
great a quick trip through the arcade
was no problem for Damien so it's on to
the next challenge
stability Paul gives Damien the command
steady then uses the dog to help him sit
down with his tail wagging it's clear to
see Damien's happy to work another great
signal Paul uses Damien to help stand
just as a child runs past Damien
maintains his focus the exact reaction
he needs were the same to happen with
his forever family Paul makes a minor
adjustment to Damien's position but
appears happy with the dog's performance
[Music]
a second stability test is meant to see
Damien's transition from a down state
and he handles it flawlessly
now a new challenge just for Damien
women's clothing with pack and mouth
Damien has to show patience and focus
amongst the new smells and sights and
it's no problem for the L lab in a
simple heel
Damien moves confidently and checks in
with his handler the model of a great
service dog he's in the home stretch but
there's one challenge left going down
the stairs providing stability while
facing downstairs is the toughest thing
Damien will be called upon to do he has
to show patience poise focus and
strength all while resisting his natural
urge to bolt down to even footing the
slow pace is grueling
but when trainer Paul sees Damian wait
patiently on even the last step it
appears he's nailed it not even Paul can
contain his excitement for the pub
while Damien turned in a virtuoso
performance on his exam the trainer's
still have to discuss if after two years
in a name change he's finally ready to
graduate back at doggy do-good Damien's
classmates wait to hear his fate the
tension is palpable then they see him
he's done it
presenting the newest graduate from
doggie doo good Damien the two-year old
yellow lab tomorrow he and Paul will set
off to meet the labs forever family just
as Damien was trained to help people now
his family will have to be trained in
handling Damien the process can take
anywhere from one to three weeks the
Paul will be there to help the whole
time it's been a long two years of
training and Damien is rightly excited
he takes a well-deserved victory lap as
his classmates look on their schooling
has just begun but if they keep up the
progress they've shown this last month
maintain focus and stop eating so much
grass like the newest alumni Mian they
too will soon graduate
puppy prep
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]